football is a ban from betting on any
other part of the game and I've intern
is being found guilty of betting within
football we don't know the specifics of
the case the hearing was held yesterday
at the fa's headquarters at Wembley and
we're still awaiting the full findings
but he has admitted to 232 breaches of
the fa rules between a four-year period
up to January 2021 and as it stands now
he's banned from playing any form of
football until January of next year he
can return to train in September and not
only is this a blow for Brentford it's a
potential impediment to his transfer
ability because actually he's quite an
in-demand player he would be one of
those coveted Strikers in the summer
transfer window his goals have helped
Brentford reached Ninth Place in the
Premier League this season with two
matches remaining really just showing
the impact that he has made within the
game and what a rise it has been helping
Brentford establish themselves as a at
Premier League team as for the eight
month ban it is not as long as some
others in the past an 18-month band was
given to Joey Barton who was playing for
Burnley at the time but certainly this
is a sign of how football tries to
clamped down on betting to protect the
Integrity of the game even though Ivan
Tony is one of those players who
actually has a betting sponsor on the
front of his better in front of his
Brentford shirt